welcome to the digital Rose battle
exclusive this is our first ever naked
roast battle Weiner tank saw our first
battle er just got off riding for the
roast of Bruce Willis a job he also did
naked he has a podcast called the meme
boys which he does with his roommate
every week everyone slept your balls
together for comics bad
[Applause]
challenger is his podcast co-host and
his roommate you saw him with his
clothes on during last year's Rose
battle give it up for the mean boy with
I'm hoping a nice penis let's find out
right now it's Kate Kerry
[Applause]
I am so excited for this Rose battle you
guys I don't know what to expect when
they take off the robes but I can say
that each of their bodies looks like the
type of penis that you don't want to
encounter it's less mortifying once you
get naked then looking at you in that
robe the goddamn kool-aid man that would
be high praise oh this is like an
episode of naked and afraid where
they're naked and we're afraid wait how
do these guys feel right now about to
get naked on national kazar Nicki I feel
soft I think I just found out viagra is
not as powerful looking at Jeff Ross so
it's hard to get shoved up when the
hottest chick on stage is Anthony jazel
Mac
[Applause]
[Music]
alright boys let's see them
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
man I look down at his even worse than I
thought because I knew I was soft I did
not know I was this soft you guys this
is pretty right I mean goddamn it
doesn't keep stick kind of just look
like one of his balls you look like
you're about to it up in a porno
[Laughter]
[Applause]
alright let's do Oh
Moses I think we just killed the disney
viacom merger good whatever that is
let's roast
thank you Jesus and his birthday suit
tonight because it's the only outfit he
didn't get by winning a hot wing
challenge dude you look like you got
stung by a swarm of Applebee's
I've lived with Connor for a long time
but we still keep learning new stuff
about each other like tonight I found
out that's a dude strip he's my best
friend and I don't know what's sadder
the fact that he's gonna die in three
months or the fact that will need
pallbearers for his urn
this man is so unhealthy I've seen him
clog toilets with his pee connor looks
great naked he was also molested as a
child so I guess we know his stomachs
not the only part of his body that's
totally ripped
screw Keith I was molested because one
of us was a cute kid here's how
unlovable you were Keith your father
abandoned you your mother remarried to a
Nazi and when you were 16 you tried to
hang yourself your real dad didn't love
you enough to teach you how to tie a tie
and your stepdad didn't love you enough
to teach you how to tie in news Conor
you look like you're about to crash your
racecar bed into a black lives matter
protest less joke please
despair I do look a little racist but
Keith hates all races I'm talking 100
meter dash marathons 5 caves relay races
Porto Ricans Keith's bisexual which
means he men and ugly women it's
true I am bisexual Connor looks like
every guy that's ever called me
but he acts like every guy that's ever
called me daddy
[Applause]
don't touch me Jeff
what do you like in this one I would say
you guys have some balls coming up here
but I'm not so sure anymore you guys do
a podcast together what's the podcast
called me boys the mean boys yeah that's
great man you're like besties you're
roommates I love this guy's my best
friend yeah I had no one I'd rather rose
petal in the world it's awesome
except for anyone with not their dick
out yeah be grabby cool but maybe a hot
chick next time I don't know I think I'm
gonna let Anthony weigh in before I
before I vote Conor McSpadden and Keith
Carey right I want to get this right
because I will never say them again dude
I'm a mean handsome white guy I'm just
waiting for you to die or get me to so I
can take your spot
Connor if you were as handsome as me you
wouldn't be naked right now but listen
what you guys did tonight
bravery is the wrong word I would say
desperate well that's still courageous
you know what I'm going to give it to ki
I'm supposed to say about your balls
Keith when you laugh they go up in your
body and I want you guys to go back and
watch because if you focus in they tuck
they lift up into his
Wow
[Applause]
I'm just holding something get a
thumbnail for this video you know what
it seems like it's almost a tie why
don't we have these guys play basketball
you were so funny but I was completely
bowled over by that Paul Bearer joke and
I didn't even mean to do that
I was I was that that the Paul Bearer
joke for the urn was like one of the
best jokes I've heard in a while and so
I'm gonna I'm gonna give it to Connor
cuz it's yeah but it was tough man keep
great job but Connor
Keith you came out swinging I'll say
that it really was super funny
it really was I love both of you you are
two of my favorites Connor that
pallbearers for Zurn joke was my
favorite joking around and you
definitely had great comebacks which
made it a great back-and-forth but as
far as like consistently hitting home
runs I had Keith four to three on that
one so congratulations
those battle
[Applause]
[Music]
anywhere else they promise everyone
close next
[Applause]